hmm
[Music]
this isn't funny amber when do you like
to play a game tara
[Laughter]
doors unlocked
all doors locked
doors unlocked
hello
it's happening
three attacks so far do you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
something about this one just feels
different
samantha
i'm i know who you are
i've been through this
a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is gonna keep coming for
you
are you ready
for this
never
stop
there's certain rules to surviving
the attacks were all on people related
to the original killers
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
hello
it's an honorary
you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
[Music]
if you're gonna run
do it
are
now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of you
who wants to hunt
and consume blood
[Music]
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
hey dr mike you and i should stay in
touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take them
are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am venom
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
[Music]
get out of here
[Music]
fear
is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
oh my god
this
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me it's
only going to get worse for you
take it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say thank you
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
i'm vengeance
and dead all over
i got you
[Music]
oh
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
are you being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you names tails okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no idea
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
[Music]
if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
we're here to see others dumbledore
that would be my brother
the world as we know it is coming undone
grindelwald's pulling it apart with hate
if we're to defeat him you'll have to
trust me
[Music]
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous wizard in over a
century
a major zoologist his indispensable
assistant
wizard descended from a very old family
a school teacher
[Music]
and
a muggle dumbledore said i give you
something
are you kidding me right now who
wouldn't like our chances
[Music]
i have to save the world are we
[Music]
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
swivel but delicately i'm swiveling
right you're seven
[Music]
oh whoa with the knuckles
[Music]
begin
okay
what is this place the room we require
[Music]
three points to hufflepuff
[Music]
very dangerous forgotten wrong hands
mess you up where did you guess it
i got for christmas
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
his exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you
may very well mean the difference
between life
and death
your reputation precedes you
i have to admit i wasn't expecting an
invitation back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting two versus one he's gotta be
kidding
what the hell
[Music]
smoke in the air
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
hmm
so
[Music]
um
ah
i got eyes on the
[Music]
go to the animals
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello
keep it steady
damn i don't see it you see it settle
down kid she can't run forever
[Music]
as we prepare for ignition
flight recorders are on t minus five
four
three
two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
to infinity
and
this is six
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
everybody here for the interview
me too
what do you drive
i got the jet bike
they're ready to see you mr crew oh good
great
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
distinguished villains
my name is cru
i feel like i'm talking too loud even
though our proximity doesn't require
this kind of volume
you seriously think a puny little child
can be a villain
yes i am pretty despicable you don't
want to cross me
come back when you've done something
evil to impress me
i'll distract them
i'll handle this
this is the biggest day of my life
this kid just all something from the
world's villains in the world
time to strike now i will be a
supervillain
now all i need is otto where is ato
are you pulling on my legs right now
otto where's the stone oh
[Music]
oh
you just trade my future
for a petra
[Music]
oh i didn't mean to scare you now where
is groom
i've been waiting for this moment
for a very long time
this is the one
this is the one that's going to change
everything
this
is blackout
[Music]
five thousand years ago kondok was a
melting pot of cultures wealth
power and magic
yet most of us had nothing
except for the chains around our necks
conduct needed a hero
instead they got me
i did what needed to be done
and they imprisoned me for it
now
five thousand years later
i'm free and i give you my word
no one will ever stop me again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you don't make it easy
you got a minute oh what
when how does how did she
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adorable
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i
i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you